on l'appelle la malédiction des pharaons
une vengeance contre les aventuriers
osant profané les tombes au sacré des
pyramides 1699 un navire polonais
transportant deux momies et hanté par
des visions spectrale essuie de
violentes tempêtes 1803 quatre membres
d'une expédition entre dans la pyramide
de khéphren et n'en ressortent jamais
1922 le tombeau de toutankhamon est
ouvert et une série de mort atroce
s'abat sur l'équipe responsable de
l'excavation lors des 91 m et qui
suivirent aucune autre tombe ne fut
profanée clair surtout de ne pas louer
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé r toxiques
qu'on trouve habituellement dans des
grottes tous des tombes qui sont restés
fermés longtemps à vous le voyez la
pyramide ne renvoie attaque de trois
côtés à 4 comme les pyramides de gizeh
gardez-moi la crise que ce truc doit
faire mal et qu'on peut pas entrer là
dedans j'te repris c'est la découverte
du siècle
vous êtes tard et pour celles gérées par
la barre avec vous restez groupés et
surtout ne touchez à rien on garde ça
qu'est ce que ces inscriptions raconte
une histoire c'est un avertissement pour
avertir de quoi
il faut qu'on sorte du fil un après
l'autre c'est un cul de sac
c'est un la pirate il semble avoir été
construit dans un plus précis l'empêcher
de sortir quiconque ibm 3
c'est paris
tha
à